mysterious illness in children that may
be linked to the corona virus is turning
up in more states across the country and
it's blamed for at least three deaths
and dozens of other patients have it in
New York senior medical correspondent
dr. Tara Narula talked to a mother in
Illinois whose son became seriously ill
it hit so quick it was like one minute
he was fine in the next minute it's like
he woke up with this weird strange fever
Sara Garcia says her son Nolan's health
went downhill fast earlier this month at
one point his fever almost reached a
hundred and five degrees when she
couldn't get the fever down she took her
six-year-old to the ER I didn't know
what it was but my doctor had told me
the only real virus going around right
now would be Kovac but I was thinking
well none of us are sick we didn't go
out so I'm not quite sure you know what
this is doctors told her Nolan's
coronary arteries were enlarged a sign
often associated with Kawasaki disease
hours later nolan tested positive for
Kovan 19:00 it wasn't typical
what you're thinking coded symptoms it
wasn't a coffee was not having a hard
time breathing
Nolan is one of more than 130 reported
cases of pediatric multi-system
inflammatory syndrome in the u.s.
hospitals in 11 states and DC say they
have treated patients in New York where
93 cases are being investigated
officials are warning parents to watch
out for fever rash and abdominal pain
there's a spectrum of disease and so
what we're seeing here is probably just
the very most severe spectrum of this
presentation in children dr. Sam
Dominguez is a pediatric infectious
disease specialist at Children's
Hospital Colorado he says there are
several unknowns about this illness
including if it's linked to corona virus
it's a very rare disease and we're
working very hard on hospitals around
the country to think about this and our
best approach to caring for these
children some kids with this syndrome
can get sick quickly if you notice any
warning signs it is important to call
your pediatrician
dr. Dominguez also told us parents
should not be afraid of hospitals which
can provide treatments children need at
this time very good to know thank you
very much dr. tara nurullah very scary